man is unlike anything else in creation
he sits there
with these divine qualities and
simultaneously these
these very earthly qualities
[Music]
we're told in genesis chapter 1 26
that god has made man in his image and
by his likeness has he made him
and this is a really important
distinction because man is unlike
anything else in creation
he sits there with these divine
qualities
and simultaneously these these very
earthly
qualities and it's the tension between
the two the tension between the earthly
and the divine that comes to uh comes to
define
a man's interaction with other humans
and the divine throughout
the book in genesis chapter 2 verse 5
on the day the lord god made earth and
heavens no shrub of the field being yet
on the earth
and no plant of the field yet sprouted
for the lord
god had not caused rain to fall on the
earth there was no human to till the
soil
and wetness would well from the earth to
water all the surface of the soil
then god fashioned the human humus from
soil
and blew into his nostrils the breath of
life and the human became
a living creature this is robert alter's
translation of genesis
and he's trying to he's trying to depict
for us
in english the word play that's there uh
in in hebrew uh adam
just means the human being and the human
being the word play there
it was was taken from adam which means
from the soil
god taking this human being from the
soil but note
he is into the human once god
blows into his nostrils you see the
breath of god you see something of the
divine
coming down to the human it's really a
thing of beauty you see this
this kind of majestic creature unlike
the other ones thus far
and i think the most startling statement
in the entirety of these opening
chapters that the first three chapters
of genesis
comes now here in verse 18 and the lord
god said
it is not good for the human to be alone
i shall make him a sustainer beside him
for the first time if you go back to
genesis chapter 1
god repeatedly says and it was good and
it was good
and it was good every act of creation
is good all things are good in this
narrative
but now we are going to get a key
insight with regards to the human
and really what it means to be a human
because for the first time we are told
so that something is not good
and it is not good that man is alone
this comes to help us understand
that we aren't these autonomous beings
answerable to no one
we would like to say we're only
answerable to god but even here we
understand
there is something about what it means
to be the human here that being in
isolation is wholly unacceptable
and so what does god do he starts
fashioning animals
the lord fashioned from the soil each
beast of the field and each fowl of the
heavens
and brought each to the human to see
what he would call it whatever
the human called the living creature
that was its name
but of course we're we're told after all
of this
there was no sustainer found for the
human
in these animals verse 21 and the lord
god cast a deep slumber on the human and
he slept
and he took one of his ribs and closed
over the flesh where it had been
and the lord god built the rib he had
taken from the human into a woman
and he brought her to the human and the
human said
this one at last bone of my bones and
flesh of my flesh
this one shall be called woman for for
man was this one
taken it's this beautiful moment
because what we see here with regards to
humankind's notion of personhood
is that it's a corporate personhood is
that to
understand what it means to be a human
person
isn't simply to be a unique individual
surrounded by all these other unique
individuals made in the same
way but rather we are in a sense
incomplete
with we can't even name who we are
we have no identity if we are not in a
relationship to another
human person in fact look at the look at
the
uh the poem that adam offers to us this
one at last bone of my bones and flesh
of my flesh
notice he names this one precisely in
the way in which
he's going to name the animals this one
shall be called woman the hebrew
isha also a word that's used for wife
this one shall be called
woman isha and now notice what he does
for from man
ish was this one taken it's a beautiful
moment because now what you see
is in the act of naming this other human
being across from him
only then can he actually name himself
as a separate identity
because it's really not a separate
identity they're bound to one another
the very notion of personhood here is is
found here in this relationship from
esha
only once that's named can i actually
now have an
understanding of myself and so
this begins to stake out what the human
to the human relationship is
and then what we will see come chapter 3
is is is a fall is a disruption
is a rupture of this human-to-human
relationship and it turns out
the rupture in this human-to-human
relationship
where she is to be a sustainer to him he
has to find his
own personhood there in isha what we'll
find here
is it's also a disruption in the divine
and human
relationship thank you for watching
we hope you're enjoying our highlight
series and invite you to explore
all of hillsdale college's online
courses they are free
and for everyone who loves to learn